German Chancellor Angela Merkel is
warning that up to 70% off the German
population is likely to contract the
coronavirus as Germany reported its
third death from the disease Merkel said
the country must do everything it could
to slow the virus is spread and prevent
the healthcare system from being
overwhelmed she called on people to show
solidarity with the elderly and those
with underlying illnesses who are most
likely to die if they become infected
Michael said efforts were also being
made at the European Union level to
contain the disease and us don't stop
the economic fallout being aware of this
fact and aware of the fact that there
are vulnerable groups of the populations
people with existing illnesses older
people who can have a more serious case
of this virus if they catch it means
that our approach has to be defined by
ensuring that our health system not be
overwhelmed but rather that we have to
be able to deal with the options we have
in the health care system to ensure that
we slow down the spread of this disease
and this is why all of the measures that
we're putting into place are crucial
because they gain as time alright let's
talk now about the outbreak here in
Germany's response we have Derek
Williams from DW science with us here in
our studio and we have our chief
political editor Machado Kufa also with
us good to have you both Michaela let's
start with you what were the main
takeaways from Chancellor Merkel's
conference well first of all that she
herself mapped out really the extent of
this crisis and how serious the
situation is
calling on solidarity here in Germany
also stressing that there should be a
European response she reported from a
conference call that there had been
between the EU Member States on how to
respond some 25 billion euros
potentially on the table there and most
strikingly she was pretty much word by
word echoing the expert advice she's
receiving with the scientists sitting
there in that press conference as well
warning everyone that this crisis is
only just beginning but also call
on the responsibilities of local
authorities and every individual there
and Michelle just to make clear she
didn't announce any new measures did she
well officially what she did say is that
there would be a meeting with business
leaders this Friday to put new measures
in place but there was no new state of
affairs both in terms of the
recommendation by the German Health
Minister who again echoed scientists by
recommending that not more than 1,000
people should be in a room at any given
event and calling on the responsibility
of regional authorities to decide
whether a football match for instance
should go ahead that pretty much I think
is off the table
nationwide here in Germany right now and
also she stressed that this was a test
for society and she hopes that it will
pass it all right those are the measures
in place Derek is this the right way to
tackle the corona virus outbreak here in
Germany well I think the right way it's
probably the only way at this particular
point I mean when you're looking at 60
to 70 percent of the population
eventually contracting this infection
the only thing that you can do and this
is this was repeated over and over in
the press conference is just slow it
down and you slow the main reason that
you want to slow it down is because you
want to give the health system time to
absorb that number of people and that
was the first message that came across
the second message that actually that
was repeated over and over again as
Germany is really gonna try has to try
to protect its most vulnerable that
that's includes the elderly we know that
the corona virus infects when it infects
the elderly has a much higher mortality
rate than it does with younger people
and also people who were chronically ill
slowing it down also gives researchers
an opportunity to work on that vaccine
that was also mentioned Derek as this
outbreak spreads and people are
increasingly worried what is the most
important thing to keep in mind here on
this outbreak well there are a couple of
things that you can't really say too
often I've set them over and over again
go to the whu-oh website look at the
four or five things that you can do
personally yourself to help prevent the
spread at that coronavirus a very very
simple things that include washing your
hands
and practicing proper coughing etiquette
or sneezing etiquette some very very
simple things and the other thing that
is very important to you that you can't
say too often is that forty four out of
five people so around eighty percent of
the people that contract this virus are
not going to end up hospitalized they're
going to have mild symptoms or they're
going to have maybe even be asymptomatic
and so it's important not to panic at
this point it's important to remember
that if you get the virus it's not the
end of the world the chances are you're
going to feel it as you would possibly
like a flu or even just a bad cold and
you're going to come through it and you
and afterwards the good news is that
you'll then have immunity from it all
right those are the important things to
keep in mind there Michela just quickly
coming back to you we've been talking
about the outbreak and approach here in
Germany can you tell us what the
Chancellor said about what's being done
on the European level well she said that
Europe would want to act together then
she got a specific question from an
Italian journalist which was rather
interesting asking what that solidarity
could mean in concrete terms whether
Germany would send doctors would send
supplies and the response from anger
namakkal was that this indeed was a
stress test for all health systems and
that Germany would look into what it can
responsibly do so it's a very
interesting moment in time here with so
many European states not knowing yet how
big the force will be with which this
virus will hit the own health systems
but what is clear is that money will be
on the table that there will be a lot of
compensation for businesses across the
European Union but there were still at
the beginning of what is clearly a
political learning curve for politicians
and for all of us as society our chief
political editor Michelle echidna and
Eric Williams with us here in studio
thank you both very much well as we have
heard Italy is the worst-hit country in
Europe the leader of the northern region
around Milan is called for stricter
measures to be imposed to halt the virus
that appeal coming from Attilio Fontana
as the number of dead increases 631 and
infections exceeded 10
thousand Fontana's calling for public
transport in the north to be completely
suspended Italy is in the second day of
a nationwide lockdown room on lockdown
its streets unobscured by the usual
hordes of tourists the shutters came
down at 6:00 p.m. as bars and
restaurants closed in accordance with
new measures to stop the spread of the
corona virus the message is simple stay
at home it's advice Italians are taking
seriously after the number of confirmed
cases of covered 19 top 10,000 and the
death toll rose above 600 in Florence -
the normally bustling streets were
unusually quiet and for some the
financial consequences of the nationwide
lockdown are already beginning to bite
from around 140 plates a day we've gone
down to 25 plates this afternoon we've
decided to stay open to see if we can do
something even if it's a small thing we
have employees and rent to pay and alone
meanwhile there's trouble with the
neighbours Slovenia has closed its
border to Italy while Austria has banned
incoming journeys by train and plane
moves criticized by French president
Emanuele Macomb we don't want things to
get out of proportion that's why because
it needs to work and because it's only
the beginning of this epidemic and if we
take disproportionate measures I think
they'll be unsustainable in the long run
and that's counterproductive I sincerely
believe that these are bad decisions the
European coordination is much more
efficient for dahveed sassily european
coordination means working from home
the brussels-based president of the
European Parliament is in self-isolation
after a visit to his native Italy back
in Rome the president of the Italian
Football Federation said that the season
already suspended could be abandoned as
the coronavirus affect every pillar of
Italian life
okay let's look now at some other
coronavirus developments around the
world there is good news from China
which is officially reported its lowest
number of infections since the outbreak
started there in Wuhan the epicenter of
the outbreak workers in key sectors are
due to go back to work but elsewhere
infection rates are still increasing in
the u.s. there are now more than 1000
confirmed cases the National Guard has
been deployed to a New York suburb
that's been quarantined Greece is
shredding schools universities and
daycare centers for two weeks and in the
UK a Health Minister has announced that
she has tested positive for the virus
well it was widely reported on Tuesday
that South Korea's outbreak was waning
but now a new cluster of infections
stemming from a call center in the
capital Seoul is causing concern so far
93 people have tested positive
among the center's employees and their
families before that news correspondent
frank smith sent us this report from
Seoul on how paramedics are dealing with
the suspected cases paramedics in South
Korea are answering some tough calls in
battling the corona virus for each
prospective kovat 19 emergency like this
one they take time to put on high-level
protective gear and only one paramedic
attends to possible patients to
safeguard the team paramedic omean guan
is ready for what comes watching for the
tell-tale symptoms of corona virus high
fever and coughing cough do you mean
kovat 19 calls are difficult to respond
to because we still don't have a clear
idea of how to distinguish an actual
case from a false alarm even if a person
hasn't traveled overseas but is running
a fever we still have to assume the
worst because there's an outbreak in the
community three hospitals in Seoul have
suffered clusters of the outbreak
closing their emergency rooms other
hospitals are at times unavailable
because they're overcrowded when
transporting possible coronavirus
patients ambulances in seoul sometimes
travel long distances
South Korea CDC an emergency command
center route paramedics to designated
hospitals with space in triage in a
negative pressure isolation room which
has special ventilation to prevent the
spread of the virus after each call the
ambulances are thoroughly disinfected
and their interiors sealed to ensure
their virus free ever get infected I'm
confident that I would eventually
recover given my young age
but I live with my parents and they are
older so I'm most worried that I might
pass it on to them and there are no
guarantees that they could receive the
treatment they need in a timely manner
because emergency services are so over
stretched right now the medics at the
ambulance center are required to live in
isolation eating alone at separate times
and maintaining social distancing still
team members say that morale has
remained good we work in a field that
values teamwork above all else so
pulling in an extra shift and going out
on another call is simply a part of our
job description if they needed us to put
in more hours we simply kept our head
down and worked hard
instead of fretting about it it looks
like there will be no let-up in work
comb Yong Guan has just been dispatched
for a week with more than a dozen
colleagues to Daegu the epicentre of
South Korea's coronavirus outbreak
and Frank Smith who filed that report
joins us now from Seoul Frank first of
all how bad is the corona virus outbreak
in South Korea well today the total was
nearing 8,000 cases here in South Korea
but what's changed over the last two
days is an outbreak here in the capital
which has remained largely isolated from
the the big part of the outbreak down in
Daegu as I mentioned just 93 new cases
were announced just in the last day that
brings the total here in the South
Korean capital to 150 that took place at
a call center at a subway junction where
two Subway's lines intersect and so
there are concerns that the cluster a
new cluster could develop here in the
capital is this new spike in reported
infections Frank a sign that containment
efforts are failing well I'm not sure
about that one of the things about this
new cluster is that two of the people
that were working in that call center
that tested positive were members of
Shin Jon G that's the cult at which one
so called patients thirty-one spread the
virus to many people and sort of
initiated that outbreak in Daegu which
now includes more than 60% of those in
South Korea it's unclear whether those
two Shinzon G members at the call centre
initiated the outbreak here in Seoul so
whether or not the containment is
succeeding I think we have to compare
where we would be if the government
wasn't engaged in the intense PR
campaign to see people wash their hands
more wear masks and stay indoors more
and refrain from from large public
gatherings South Korea is a major
industrial power in Asia what impact is
the corona virus outbreak having on the
economy there well I'd like to refer
very specifically to to a story I was
told today a business person that I know
was trying to contact his accountant
he couldn't get a hold of him all day
yesterday and finally he got a call back
from his accountant late in the day and
and asked why why were you so busy all
day today in the accountant answered I
was answering calls from business people
about how they can lay off employees
that are regular workers that have you
know some 10 yrs some some experience
and and you know some seniority because
the intensity of this outbreak is having
a serious effect on businesses not just
small markets but but also large
businesses Frank thank you very much
that was reporter Frank Smith in Seoul